let's finish up Disney cember with
Tinkerbell yeah there's a strange while
where Tinkerbell was extremely popular
it's weird because the character has
been around for years and years but only
now did the popularity just explode
what's this movie the cause of it maybe
it opens literally with Tinker Bell's
birth which is kind of like what they
say in the book where a child laughs
that laughs goes to Neverland and then
suddenly a fairy is born only she's not
born like a little baby she's born fully
grown I guess it's like Pinocchio where
the personality is just intact oh why am
i analyzing it it's fairy tales and this
is obviously made for little kids who
just want to see Tinker Bell fly around
look pretty do some magic and yeah
that's about it
the story is pretty standard but you can
tell it's written for little children
Tinker Bell is looking for her place to
belong and she's put with the tinker
fairies yeah would have thought Tinker
Bell is really good at tinkering putting
things together figuring out gears and
such
unfortunately the over inventions don't
always work out that well and that means
that she can join the group of fairies
that leave Neverland and go into the
other world
so Tinker Bell gets a group of fairies
together and tries to have them teach
her how to do various other things that
can get her into the other world
unfortunately she doesn't seem very good
at it she's only good at tinkering and
making stuff and even then she's not
that great either through hard work and
determination she will make everything
really bad yeah it's one of those
stories where she screws up everything
for everyone but she also finds a way to
make it better in the end and a nice
little compromise is made actually that
is one of the few things I really admire
about this movie the message of
compromise that is to say
Tinker Bell eventually comes to terms
with her gifts but she also pushes
really hard to get what she wants and
what she feels is rightfully hers admire
films like wreck-it Ralph or Nightmare
Before Christmas that sort of say just
be happy with what you have but I also
like stories like this where it's be
happy with what you have but don't be
afraid to go a little further to fight
for what you really want sometimes you
get it sometimes you don't and sometimes
it's halfway in between like what we
have here but is there anything really
that gripping for adults in this not
especially this is something that's
written for little little kids but for
little little kids it's innocent enough
it definitely has a visual style some of
the background
very nice everyday items they use from
flowers and raindrops and such are
pretty clever and the movie is trying to
have a certain weight to it the music
especially is trying to give this grand
choir going on make it seem really huge
and you know what it's allowed I mean
look at this animation style this is
clearly trying a lot harder than
something like twice upon a Christmas
they want it to look whimsical they
wanted to feel like these characters are
alive and for the most part they do a
good job outside of that there's not
really that much to get into for adults
although I do love this one scene when
she's testing her equipment oh why does
that crack me up so much but aside from
that it's not incredibly smart but it's
not incredibly dumb either it's a nice
little innocent film to show your kids
and they'll get some creativity there
are slow moments there's times where
they need the emotion to set in but
there's also fast moments on their
scenes where they throw in the little
pop song and such I'm definitely not
gonna put it on anytime soon but if I
had little kids and they want to watch
this I'd say it's a good thing to put on
I don't have nearly enough time to look
at the dozens of sequels that came out
afterwards I know it's ironic seeing how
this was sequel month but like the movie
said compromise it's a good thing and
with that said that wraps up Disney
cember with the direct-to-dvd sequels
was it as bad as I thought it was gonna
be well in some areas it was even worse
but in some areas it was actually okay
and surprisingly in others I found
myself having a good time you can
definitely tell which films were just
rushed out and they didn't really care
about in which ones they wanted to put
the extra time and effort into even when
they didn't need to put in the extra
time and effort I'm a cat like any of
these were great but I was shocked to
find those couple they were actually
know not only tolerable but some
legitimately entertaining they were few
but I respected them and the ones that
were bad like really bad
well they'll bring us a lot of laughs in
mockery and just how awful they are at
least I can say I saw them all and I
gave them a fair shot and though I was
shocked with how bad some of them were I
was shocked by how good some of them
were I guess sometimes even when a
company like Disney just wants to throw
their table scraps at us the
can actually take those table scraps and
turn it into a good meal it doesn't
happen all the time but enough times to
get noticed folks I hope you enjoyed
this year's Disney cember and if you're
like me you're anticipating what Disney
has next to offer thanks for watching
and I'll see you next year
[Music]
you